tired of gloves that tear and leak say
bye bye to flimsy finger protection
nitrile gloves from filtres will keep
your hands safe without a cinch don't
believe me gloves from filters will
protect you from pathogens disgusting
even the peskies of chemicals perfect
for even the most corrosive lab solvents
they can even handle the toughest of
abrasions and cuts still don't believe
us watch this gloves from filters can
even withstand the toughest of
durability tests
[Music]
and they're still okay
still don't believe us just ask another
happy filters customer i've been using
gloves from filters for over two years
and let me tell you it makes all the
difference now i can never go back to
store brand thanks filters this week
only we're cutting all glove prices in
half
gloves colors purple blue and black
sizes small through extra large don't
call 858 224 9100 instead visit
filters.com where you can use the coupon
code above for these great prices on
gloves limited time only